welcome to this video Moulton yeah this
is molten Lee morphin Lee if I'm totally
probably pronouncing totally wrong but
okay I have one out of two against the
skype very strong blitz player here on
the SS see I got an Italian game let's
see with d3 probably yes going to play
this nowadays standard setup with a six
and stuff he's some home he's some plain
without castling okay it's a possible
way to play getting yeah sometimes right
after castling now um he some has the
night on g3 without him having had to
move the rook first if he cancels first
he has to play rookie 192 f1 g3 and he
has done it before so he's basically
saying okay I don't know yet if I want
the rook only one so this is kinda cool
this is a this is for example a moment
where I'm taking all these 3f takes III
has a look in a beneficial position
compared to being only one where the f
file is opening I'm just playing this
here in a super simple fashion just
taking and developing stuff yeah it's
always a question if why should
recapture with the porn or with the
Queen the Queen position is temporarily
active like on b7 but he's not
threatening to take that rook fp8 so
let's see what happens
yep why does as usual in those positions
he's super solid but it's not easy to
play for something a very substantial
let's see I can't play but like night is
70 to play but the bishop on Bishop and
pawn here this is kind of awkward
between East sixes also sometimes a move
but he still can then then you can take
p7 actually don't want that taking FTX
is awkward i wonder if i should go d5
actually why not the Queen B 7 is not
working out here i can i can take with
the rook i can i mean i have to i can
it's just the wrong way of phrasing it I
have to check with the rook and now what
does he is he threatening something
maybe deform something like that might
be threatened I don't know maybe Queenie
6 intending d takes before
it's a very it's a very equal ish kind
of position okay I'm going to take him
keep ski oh wait actually has to take
with the pawn right yeah i was thinking
this Knight takes e4 move you Queenie
6v6 I know thats it thats really bogus
okay I'm going to take there is really
no big issue with that the only idea
that white has is to use the fact that
my knight on c6 is not particularly well
placed yeah exactly you can try that try
to put a knight on d5 and trying to get
some kind of pressure out of that my
experience is that it is usually a bit
awkward for like you have to be precise
but when you are it done now if you are
better word if you are you're normally
not in any danger you're going to see
what happens yeah so knight to e7 now
trying to get rid of this night
I have to be going to e6 or not no it's
not that's not so bad sometimes I can
even jump to a for him I have to what I
have to be a little bit cautious about
is to play c6 the move c6 is not very
very nice Knight to f5 I did not think
about this month that's kind of awkward
I have six was a lazy move it was it was
a lazy mood not not very very much
necessary
going to going to go for counter play
with this idea if you takes Knight eggs
I have counter play against you for and
f3 this kind of thing I need some need
some play on my own here so if i go edge
voice is a move maybe i can prepare that
can prepare that ok a nicely played
nicely played
check can you take cannot take a c7 now
because of the pin time warning check
its it works both ways on this pin so
I'm down to one minute but I'm a pawn up
in this end game it's not it's not a
clear kind of thing really isn't not
easy not easy at all you might get get
the c7 pawn
and I have some weaknesses that I cannot
take myself so it's still a pin check
check
white resigns yeah that was an early
resign with 30 seconds let let her one
that I was under some pressure for quite
a while but I hope I think I defended
okay made one or two with them hmm maybe
not so great mousse but I'm okay with
that this is an ending which is okay
it's not much fun to play with it's
something that black should hold with
precise play and I'm go see I am a
little bit simply because of the
queenside knight on c6 this kind of
situation here is a bit tricky the
knight on c6 is just defending if I of
all the time and I'm looking at
controlled square so this is never so
nice for night and if i move the night
away as we have seen later I managed to
regroup here a little bit getting this
night away this 36 now I'm ready to play
f6 to make the night here that I can
move it but the problem is i can never
really go c 6 because this is this
weekend's my structure far too much if
we look at this Here I am his he has
this square and this square and so on is
really awkward so I have to stay put
like here here and yeah around here it
gets interesting now I had this counter
play idea which I like maybe I'm really
okay the night only six is doing a very
good job defending this and if he plays
Knight 285 I'm I can come with this for
the moment the computer is giving by the
minimum match 0.3 which is maybe fair
don't know if it is more than that I'm
clear it's clear that i'm still kind of
defending it's a position where i can
never be better or anything but i think
it's kind of ok I shouldn't I shouldn't
lose ready yeah and this gives some
counter play is the X in the he i am
here is interesting he actually should
have done that I'm sorry tape with the
roof
you should have done that for night f5
without capturing first here I have
counter play rook cd8 was strong now 490
xe4 yes okay I didn't see the move I was
already under some some try time time
pressure check yet he I'm better yeah
because of the because of the pinning
business takes takes check and 94 he
didn't see that yeah yeah i'm i'm with
the better where did the better end game
yeah he was probably a bit frustrated so
he gave away one walk horn due to the
check to the pin now that was an early
resignation but he has a hard time to
avoid even losing the b2 upon and it's
just too much I'm also much more active
with the king so it was a good game i
hope thanks for watching